Bonjour si vous faites partie du gros million
cinq d'étudiants inscrits à l'université
française, bonjour aussi si vous n'en faites
pas ou plus partie, ou si vous attendez encore
que ParcoursSup trace votre voie.
On aime tout le monde, ici.
Alors parlons peu, parlons des universités.
Jusqu'au XIIe siècle, l'éducation était
surtout possible via les écoles monastiques,
qui formaient les futurs moines mais aussi
quelques laïcs, directement dans les monastères.
On trouvait aussi de rares écoles publiques
créées en 829, et les écoles cathédrales
qui servent à éduquer les futurs clercs
du royaume.
Les nobles préfèrent éduquer leurs enfants
à domicile, et les villageois restent majoritairement
analphabètes, pas besoin de savoir l'épeler
pour tirer une charrette.
-C'était le résumé le plus rapide de six
siècles d'éducation que j'ai jamais vu.
-Alors qu'à mon époque, les écoles antiques
fournissaient un enseignement très complet
et...
-Ouiii, mais on est au XIIe siècle là.
Pas vrai?
-Le but ici n'est pas de vous résumer toute
l'histoire de l'éducation au Moyen Âge parce
que ce serait très long, mais de vous présenter
l'apparition des universités comme le titre
l'indique.
Au début du XIIe siècle, donc, on trouve
surtout à Paris des «écoles cathédrale»,
la plus réputée étant celle de Notre-Dame.
-Ces écoles sont sous le contrôle de l'évêque.
On les retrouve sur l'île de la cité, où
les maîtres enseignent la théologie, l'écriture
sainte, le chant, le latin...
On reste cloisonné à des enseignements très
pratiques pour futurs clercs même si les
élèves les plus doués peuvent aussi demander
à apprendre les arts libéraux et se spécialiser
dans l'un d'entre eux.
-Ah! Les arts libéraux, c'est mon domaine.
Il s'agit d'un ensemble de matières héritées
des écoles antiques, les meilleures.
Parmi elles on trouve le trivium, composé
de la grammaire, la rhétorique et la dialectique.
-Aaah, trivium parce qu'il y a trois matières...
-Et le quadrivium composé de l'arithmétique,
la géométrie, la musique et l'astronomie.
-Aaaah, quadrivium parce que...
-Oui, on a compris.
Ces arts libéraux réapparaissent lentement
dans l'éducation à partir du IXe siècle.
Il faut préciser aussi que la grammaire n'a
rien à voir avec ce qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
et consiste plutôt en de l'explication de
texte.
Au XIIe siècle, donc, l'île de la Cité
est peuplée de clercs étudiants, de jeunes
ecclésiastiques quoi, et de leurs maîtres,
le tout sous la supervision de l'évêque,
mais certains décident alors de saper cette
autorité en partant s'installer sur la rive
gauche, près de la montagne Sainte-Geneviève
et de la rue Saint Jacques.
C'est le cas de Pierre Abélard, par exemple,
qui fonde la première école de rhétorique
et de théologie qui échappe à l'autorité
de l’Église.
Abélard est l'un des grands noms de la nouvelle
pensée médiévale mais est surtout resté
connu pour son histoire d'amour quelque peu
tragique avec Héloïse, l'une de ses élèves.
Héloïse est d'ailleurs la première femme
à suivre un cursus d'arts libéraux.
BADASS.
Dans la catégorie «maîtres en rupture
avec l'école de Notre Dame» on peut aussi
citer Guillaume de Champeaux, qui crée l'école
Saint-Victor car...
-«[ses] étudiants réclamaient des raisons
humaines et philosophiques et il leur fallait
des explications humaines et intelligibles
plus que des affirmations».
-Ces nouvelles écoles sont indépendantes,
et on peut donc a priori y avoir une vision
beaucoup plus libre des enseignements.
L'école d'Abélard insiste sur l'étude d'Aristote,
qui était grandement oublié jusque là,
et de manière générale les élèves réclament
de plus en plus de débats, de réflexions
et de contestations.
-Mai 1168, quelle année.
-Cette rupture n'est pas une exception parisienne
et n'est pas non plus inédite: la première
université de ce genre nouveau est fondée
à Bologne, en 1088.
Bien sûr, ces nouveautés ne plaisent dans
un premier temps pas trop à certains religieux
qui y voient une ingérence dans leurs affaires.
Ils traitent ces nouveaux professeurs de «marchands
de mots», vu qu'à l'époque c'était plutôt
«étudie la Bible et tais-toi». Certains
maîtres sont alors accusés d'hérésie et
excommuniés, aussi à cause du fait qu'ils
enseignaient en français, cette langue vulgaire,
au lieu du latin.
-Hérésie en effet.
«On dispute publiquement, en violation
des constitutions sacrées, des mystères
de la divinité, de l'incarnation du Verbe.
L'indivisible Trinité est coupée et mise
en pièces aux carrefours.
Autant de docteurs, autant d'erreurs.
Autant d'auditoires, autant de scandales.
Autan de places publiques, autant de blasphèmes.»
-Étienne de Tournai.
-Au XIIIe siècle, Thomas d'Aquin fait carrément
des comparaisons entre la foi catholique et
la philosophie d'Aristote.
BOUM.
La création de l'université au XIIe siècle
permet donc une petite renaissance qui n'a
rien à envier à celle du XVe siècle:
les savoirs antiques sont de nouveau étudiés,
des réflexions sont menées sur la nature,
l'amour, la religion, l'humanisme, la physique,
la métaphysique, la politique...
D'anciens maîtres ou étudiants écrivent
aussi des œuvres plutôt connues, comme les
légendes arthuriennes de Geoffroy de Monmouth,
ancien étudiant d'Oxford.
Au XIIIe siècle, ces nouvelles écoles commencent
à obtenir quelques privilèges: les maîtres
sont exemptés de taxes et d'obligations militaires
en 1200, et en 1215 ils forment une coop de
maîtres qui prend le nom d'Association des
Maîtres et Étudiants de Paris, soit Universitas
magistrorum et scholarium Pariensium.
-«Université». Quel horrible accent!
-C'est le même principe que les corporations
de métier, les maîtres rédigent des règles,
des statuts et s'organisent en différentes
facultés ou studium.
Pour les plus jeunes il y a la faculté des
arts libéraux, le trivium et le quadrivium
qu'on a déjà présentés, puis ils peuvent
se spécialiser dans une faculté de théologie,
de droit canonique, de médecine...
A la fin de chaque semestre ont lieu des examens
et après cinq ou six années d'études les
élèves peuvent passer le baccalauréat,
qui apparaît aussi au XIIIe siècle.
Plein de mots connus, donc.
-Une fois leur bac en poche, ils peuvent commencer
à travailler comme assistant d'un maître
tout en préparant leur licence puis leur
doctorat.
La durée est variable selon les filières:
au XIIe siècle il fallait par exemple quinze
ans pour obtenir la licence de théologie,
fallait pas être pressé.
En 1231 le pape accorde des privilèges aux
universités européennes, qui sont alors
en pleine expansion, et fixe leur organisation.
Même si elles reçoivent ce coup de pouce
du pape, elles restent indépendantes de l’Église
au niveau local.
C'est d'ailleurs le pape qui est à l'origine
de la création de nombreuses universités.
Au XIIIe siècle, on compte une vingtaine
d'universités en Europe.
Certaines comme celles de Paris ou d'Oxford
sont générales et proposent un grand nombre
de facultés.
D'autres sont éphémères, comme celle d'Angers,
ou spécialisées: Montpellier devient renommée
pour sa faculté de médecine, Toulouse pour
la théologie...
L'école de Montpellier propose dès la deuxième
moitié du XIIe siècle un enseignement de
médecine théorique, sur les causes des maladies,
et pratique sur les moyens de traiter ces
maladies.
Et des dissections à partir du XIVe siècle,
comme celle représentée ici.
-Ouais enfin la médecine c'est pas la discipline
la plus prestigieuse à l'époque, paraît
que les étudiants en médecine sont juste
là parce qu'ils ne sont pas assez bons pour
la philosophie.
Bac S surcôté.
-Chacune de ces facultés est dirigée par
un doyen, et l'ensemble de l'université est
sous la direction du recteur.
Encore des termes dont l'emploi est resté
à peu près le même jusqu'à aujourd'hui.
Les cours sont partagés entre cours magistraux,
-Collatio,
-Explications de textes
-Lectio
-Et disputes ou discussions
-Questiones.
-Par contre, les universités manquent encore
de locaux: les maîtres louent des salles,
ou squattent même parfois des églises.
Le développement des universités permet
à de nombreux autres métiers de s'installer
dans le secteur: des copistes, relieurs
et libraires s'installent en ville et permettent
aux universités de posséder des bibliothèques
de plus en plus riches.
Mais ça, j'en ai déjà parlé dans la vidéo
sur les bibliothèques.
Les ordres mendiants, franciscains et dominicains,
sont au départ opposés à l'enseignement
des arts libéraux mais changent d'avis dès
le XIIIe siècle et ouvrent à Paris des studia,
des écoles à vocation plus religieuse que
les universités mais de bonne réputation
et dotées d'importantes bibliothèques consacrées
à la théologie, la philosophie, l'art du
sermon...
Mais du coup, qui sont les élèves, et qui
sont leurs profs?
La plupart des étudiants sont de jeunes clercs
ou futurs clercs, issus de la petite noblesse.
Ils portent alors la tonsure et ont le statut
d'ecclésiastiques.
On trouve aussi quelques étudiants issus
de la paysanneries, plus rares, mais de manière
générale les étudiants sont un peu en galère
d'argent.
Comme aujourd'hui quoi.
Certains doivent travailler pour payer leurs
études, demander l'aide des parents, voire
renoncer ou quitter rapidement l'université
pour exercer un vrai métier.
Ici, un étudiant de quatorze ans qui décide
de piétiner ses cahiers et d'entrer dans
la vie, la vraie.
Rebelle.
D'autres étudiants à l'inverse sont des
clercs déjà en poste et qui ont demandé
un congé à leur évêque pour des études
qu'ils prolongent un peu indéfiniment.
En cours, ils sont entre trois et une vingtaine
par classe et mélangés entre tous niveaux.
Certains sont sérieux, d'autres surtout chez
les étudiants en lettres fréquentent un
peu trop les tavernes et peuvent devenir des
goliards, écrivant des chansons à boire
et des poèmes satiriques.
La bonne ambiance.
Beaucoup d'étudiants viennent aussi de loin,
puisqu'il n'existe qu'une dizaine d'universités
en Europe: cela pose le problème du logement
puisque, ben, rien n'est prévu pour eux au
départ.
Ils sont parfois logés dans des cloîtres,
des chambres louées mais qui coûtent cher
ou directement chez leur maître.
Ce n'est qu'au XIIIe siècle qu'apparaissent
les collèges, qui n'ont rien à voir avec
ce qu'on connaît.
Ce sont des établissements fondés par des
riches et/ou religieux qui permettent aux
étudiants de se loger pour pas cher, mais
aussi de disposer d'une bibliothèque, d'un
petit cloître pour étudier...
-Le plus célèbre est le collège du chanoine
Robert de Sorbon, fondé en 1257 rue Coupe-Gueule.
Ça donne envie.
Il possède la meilleure bibliothèque de
Paris et se transforme ensuite en faculté
de théologie, puis en la Sorbonne, que vous
connaissez apparemment.
-On peut aussi citer le collège de Fortet,
fondé en 1394 grâce au testament d'un chanoine
qui «ordonne qu’il soit fondé un collège
de huit écoliers dans l’une des maisons
qu’il possédait à Paris, savoir la première
située rue des Cordiers, près des frères
prêcheurs; la seconde située au clos Brunel
et la troisième située rue Saint Victor,
selon qu’il paraîtrait convenable à son
exécuteur testamentaire.»
Aujourd'hui, il en subsiste la tour Calvin
que voici.
Au XVe siècle on compte environ cinquante
de ces collèges dans Paris, mais ils ne permettent
toujours de loger que 10% des étudiants.
Après leurs études, ils peuvent devenir
professeurs, bien sûr.
D'autres sont religieux, ou intègrent certaines
cours princières ou épiscopales.
Passons aux maîtres, maintenant: au début
des universités, au XIIe siècle, n'importe
quel maître pouvait enseigner sans devoir
passer d'examen.
-Vous vous prenez pour un enseignant?
-Plus de capes, moins de CAPES.
-Les étudiants choisissaient alors leurs
maîtres selon leur réputation, et ils enseignaient
souvent gratuitement en exerçant un autre
métier lié à leur discipline à côté.
Souvent, c'était des religieux.
Avec l'essor des universités, leur métier
gagne en reconnaissance.
Ils touchent enfin un salaire, qui ne leur
permet pas un niveau de vie très élevé
mais là encore, rien de nouveau sous le soleil,
et peuvent se faire aider de suppléants qui
sont souvent des étudiants de niveau licence
ou doctorant.
Certains deviennent très réputés, comme
Abélard, Thomas d'Aquin...
Ils peuvent rester maîtres toute leur vie
ou poursuivre leur carrière en entrant au
service de princes ou rois, en tant que précepteurs
ou même conseillers.
D'autres finissent par se retirer dans un
monastère pour une retraite bien méritée.
Il existe aussi des rivalités entre maîtres,
on peut ainsi citer au XIIe siècle le conflit
sanglant entre maître Arnoul d'Orléans et
maître Bernard de Meung qu'il décrit en
ces mots:
«Vous avez présentement chez vous un professeur
idiot qui me calomnie et ne cesse d'inventer
des choses qu'on ne devrait jamais dire contre
un poète.
Corrigez-le, c'est dans votre intérêt;
si moi je ne le démolis pas, ce n'est pas
à cause de lui mais par respect pour vous.
Que se taise donc la langue maudite, autrement
ma riposte fera éclater au grand jour sa
stupidité».
Bref, les universités apportent bon nombre
de savoirs et de réflexions qui préfigurent
la Renaissance et ironiquement c'est au moment
de cette Renaissance avec un grand R que les
universités ne sont plus tellement au top.
Leur enseignement, surtout dans le domaine
de la théologie, peine à se renouveler parce
que ça fait trois siècles que maîtres et
étudiants tournent en rond autour des même
textes, des même questions, sans chercher
à y apporter de nouveautés.
Certaines universités passent alors sous
l'autorité de l'Etat, ou de princes, et deviennent
des centres de formation pour les futurs administrateurs
du royaume plutôt que des lieux de cultûûre.
Voilà, c'est tout pour cet épisode un peu
plus court que les précédents mais ça fait
du bien de temps en temps.
On se retrouve à la fin du mois pour un Gentes
Dames Badass mêlant deux de mes passions:
-L'hydromel et les fajitas?
-Les femmes badass et les dinosaures.
En attendant pouce-bleutez, partagez et tipez
à volonté
et aurevoir!